There is no truth here from the beginning There
is only fiction
I also know that Mr. Rokka was not a narrow public at first
On top of that, Mr. Rokka tried to materialize the fiction and
I and Mr. Kuro were public  I'm trying to make you believe in the fiction that there isn't.
Baan'n
ana
So to speak, this seems to be fiction.
It's enough.
If it
's not easy for everyone to accept a single truth in a net space where a wide variety of values swirl, I'd lik
e to present a truth that seems to match that wide variety of value
.  Aragami Nanase existed with a good pendulum solution, and I couldn't get rid of my desires.
Some of them should have been supported by disapproval.
Repeat three more times.
All you have to do is make me think that Mr. Rokka's bill is not enough to pass
[Music]
That's why such a strategy holds true.
The answer that I decided to do was so vicious